with so many moving parts and such high
standards to uphold it's always possible
that something is going to go wrong on
the set of Game of Thrones throughout
the show's eight seasons a number of
performers have suffered for their art
here's how Sandor Clegane is so pure
'some that the character earned one of
the coolest nicknames in all of Game of
Thrones the hound he survived trial by
combat a massacre by the phrase and
being thrown off a cliff by Brienne of
Tarth the actor who portrays Clegane
Rory McCann got a bit battered - you
want to cut my throat yeah the 7th
season episode beyond the wall finds the
Hound and others waging war against the
night king and his forces Clegane has to
carry a white through much of the trek
forcing McCann to - here and there
sometimes across real ice while the
actor playing the undead creature
twisted and tumbled on his shoulders it
all left McCann with such intense pain
that he sat for an interview with the
Sydney Morning Herald while holding an
ice pack to his leg McCann told the
paper I had this guy on my shoulder for
days and days it didn't work with a
dummy so I had to carry a real guy and
we had to run and run
Jon Snow is the sensitive brooding and
sometimes pouty leading man of the Game
of Thrones universe but you can't blame
him for that really because a lot of bad
stuff has happened to it
through the bush plane John snow has
been much more pleasant for actor Kit
Harington Game of Thrones brought him
international stardom an Emmy nomination
and the hand in marriage of co-star Rose
Leslie but also quite nearly permanent
mutilation filming a dragon flying scene
for the show's eighth season involved
Harrington mounting a massive flailing
mechanical apparatus called the buck his
character had to almost fall off
forcing Harrington to hold on and to
endure a tight squeeze and my right
bolli got trapped and I didn't have time
to say stall and I was being swung round
fortunately Harrington finished the
scene and escaped with all of his parts
intact since season two actress Jimmy
Whelan has played Yara Greyjoy the now
undisputed queen of the Iron Islands
she's a relentless warrior and commander
of a ship called the black wind and a
lot of her scenes involve battles at sea
Whelan was filming a scene near Belfast
Northern Ireland for the seventh season
of Game of Thrones which she sustained
some kind of injury requiring
hospitalization on September 14 2016
Whelan posted to her Instagram account a
photo of some old fashioned Hospital
issue underwear the pic came with a wry
caption from Whelan describing how a
ward nurse offered her the undergarments
because she arrived at the hospital
quote a bit suddenly and unprepared
Weiland never confirmed exactly what
happened to her on set or how but she
soon rejoined the series eight seasons
of Game of Thrones built up to the long
night the episode featuring the Battle
of Winterfell the apocalyptic
confrontation between a massive army of
zombie-like White Walkers controlled by
the night king and the assorted united
human contingents of Westeros taking a
break from fighting one another it's one
of the largest sequences ever filmed for
Game of Thrones which made for an
intense grueling shoot [ __ ] down my god
redone in March 2019 Entertainment
Weekly reported that one of the series's
regular actresses suddenly collapsed on
set while filming the scene that
involved what the outlet described as a
lot of standing still a crew member
noticed the fall right away and called
out for a medic who promptly tended to
the unnamed actress the official line
the actress fainted went
home and return to the set the following
day part of what makes Game of Thrones
so thrilling is the scenery the series
has shot in exotic locations all over
the world and filmed many sequences in
the breathtaking rocky wilds of Northern
Ireland which stood in nicely for the
hinterlands of the Seven Kingdoms and
beyond while it looks great on screen
the area opposed its own unique
challenges for the production
particularly the elements the weather
can get awfully brutal just off the sea
in the northern United Kingdom while
shooting near the village of Valentine
2011 the crew erected a pole tent where
workers and extras could have lunch then
winds from Hurricane Katia ripped
through the area and tore the whole
thing down according to the Belfast
Telegraph in the chaos four men and one
woman sustained minor injuries enough to
briefly land them in the hospital check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about Game
of Thrones are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]